MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
everyone.
We are extremely thrilled today
to host the Alexander
String Quartet.
Formed just over 30 years ago,
they're one of the premier
quartets worldwide.
Members Zak Grafilo, Frederick
Lifsitz, Paul Yarbrough, and
Sandy Wilson are based in San
Francisco, where they serve as
the ensemble in residence for
San Francisco performances.
You can find more about their
ongoing tours and their
discography at ASQ4.com, while
San Francisco performances is,
of course, at performances.org.
The ASQ has completed a series
of string quartet cycles,
including the complete Beethoven
and the complete
Shostakovich, both
very well done.
Their latest works on the
Allegro Media Group include
pieces by Gershwin and Kern.
Today's program will be
announced from the stage, but
as always, we'll have time
for some Q&A at the end.
After all, what is the string
quartet but the most elevated
musical conversation
in live music?
So without further ado, please
join me in welcoming the
Alexander String Quartet
to Google.
Thanks a lot.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: It's
an incredible
pleasure to be here.
This setting-- this very
setting, with people gathered
around comfortably, television
cameras, was exactly what
Mozart and Haydn had in mind
when they were composing their
greatest quartets in the
1780s, and in Haydn
case, into the 1790s.
The genre really started in the
1750s. '50s A young Haydn
started writing some
string quartets.
A great many composers in
southern Germany and northern
Italy wrote quartets, although
the instruments had been
around for some time
before that.
But this idea of the
conversation in the music was
really paramount to the
string quartet.
And as I said, Haydn and his
younger counterpart Mozart did
everything they could to bring
the quartet to the point when
Mozart died in 1791, the quartet
was just a vehicle
that was going to last,
and it did last.
Almost every great composer
to this very day has
written at least one.
We used to have garages full
of scores sent to us from
composers around the world.
Now we have mailboxes full of
them in electronic format.
It hasn't stopped.
This first work we're going to
play for you is one of the
last quartets that
Mozart wrote.
In fact, I think this is the
last quartet that he wrote.
Not the last work.
This dates June of 1790, and
he and Haydn had written
quartets back and forth for each
other, and they actually
played in a quartet together
with two other composers.
It would've been wonderful to
eavesdrop on those evenings.
But this quartet was written
as a set of three--
one of a set of three that was
dedicated to the King of
Prussia, who was an
amateur cellist.
He was either a really great
cellist, or Mozart really
wanted to impress him, because
the cello writing is extremely
difficult in this work.
No pressure, Sandy.
And we're going to share
with you the first
movement of this quartet.
It starts off using the forces
in absolute unison, and
branches out from there.
[MUSIC - MOZART]
PAUL YARBROUGH: For our next
selection, we've chosen to
play two movements from a
quartet by Franz Schubert.
Schubert was born just a few
years after Mozart's death.
He was born in the same city,
Vienna, in 1797, and lived
only until 1828.
He died at the age of
31, having written
more than 1,000 works.
He was an incredibly prolific
composer for
such a short lifespan.
I think he did nothing but
write music pretty
much all day long.
The two movements that we'd like
to play from a quartet
that has a nickname, Death
and the Maiden.
This quartet was written
after a poem by a man
named Matthias Claudius.
And the poem is very short.
And first, Schubert wrote a
song on the poem, and the
story is, death has come to take
away this young girl, and
he's very seductive.
And he says, come with me.
You're going to love it.
It's great.
She says, no, no, no.
I'm too young.
I can't go yet.
And he says, no,
you're coming.
So basically, that's the poem.
And the singer who sings
it has to kind
of do both the voices--
the voice of the maiden and
the voice of death.
Anyway, later on, after having
written the song, Schubert
wrote a variations movement on
the theme from the song, and
that's the movement that we're
going to play from the string
quartet, which then took the
title of the poem as its
nickname for the
entire quartet.
The quartet, which is four
movements, is very much in the
same vein as the poem, and
there's an amazing thing that
Schubert does, which
is going between
a dark minor tonality--
very ominous--
to something that's brighter,
more optimistic.
Not necessarily happy,
but kind of serene.
And it's such a beautiful
juxtaposition between these
two poles of expression.
The first movement that we'll
play is actually the second
movement from the quartet, and
it's titled Andante Con Moto.
And this is the theme and
variation of movement.
And then we'll also play the
following movements, Scherzo
and Trio, and in that movement,
you'll hear the
contrast between the minor
and the major and the
darkness and the light.
[MUSIC - FRANZ SCHUBERT,
"DEATH AND THE MAIDEN"]
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: It's
interesting that Schubert and
Beethoven were alive, working
quite hard at the same time,
at the end of both
of their lives.
And Schubert and Beethoven, as
far as we know, never met.
They lived within blocks
of one another.
And despite this impression of
Beethoven being this very
tall, imposing figure that you
see in statues, especially in
Vienna, he apparently
was quite short.
And Schubert was even shorter.
And Schubert was very shy, and
he just apparently could never
get up the nerve to go and speak
to Beethoven, of course,
which was difficult also toward
the end of Beethoven's
life with hearing issues.
But Beethoven, at the end
of his life, did ask his
assistant to bring in some of
the scores of this young
gentleman's music, and
was really, really
blown away by it.
He could read it like a book.
The other kind of ultimate spam
box was the coat room in
the home of [INAUDIBLE]
the great poet, playwright,
and philosopher.
He had an assistant that sort
of screened his mail.
And Schubert had a handful
of songs--
of poems of [INAUDIBLE]
he had put to music.
Those poems, those songs, the
lieder that he wrote, have
been what has made a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] poetry famous in
every region of the world, where
it probably wouldn't
have been read otherwise.
But at the time, [INAUDIBLE]
didn't really know who this guy
was, and never opened it
to see the manuscript of these
songs that had been written
based on his poetry.
These composers, looking back,
with hindsight, you can always
tell a good one.
But at the time, it's really
hard to see what a winner is.
But somehow, time seems to have
been very kind to these
handful of composers, and you'd
think that the string
quartet was only written and
played in Vienna, if you heard
the first part of
this program.
But we're going to move to the
20th century, and to England.
Not necessarily to London, but
to England, and the composer
Benjamin Britten.
Britten wrote three beautiful
string quartets, and he wrote
earlier than he wrote
the string quartets.
In 1933, when he was
20 years old--
19, I guess, officially when
he wrote these works.
He was born, as I said in
1913, and died in 1976.
He wrote three divertimenti.
Three sort of fun pieces,
although I wouldn't
necessarily call these
necessarily fun pieces.
But they are fun to play, and
they're fun to listen to.
But as was anything with
Benjamin Britten's music,
there's a note of seriousness.
He was a lifelong pacifist.
As a boy in boarding school,
he witnessed beatings that
were condoned, and perhaps that
was that type of thing
that led him to become a
conscientious objector during
World War II.
He was in this country.
He wrote the famous War Requiem,
which is a real
statement against man's
inhumanity to man.
And he took his own art--
used his own art
to express his feelings.
His innermost feelings about the
way he viewed the world.
Composers have often used the
string quartet, because it's
this incredibly transparent,
intimate art form, to express
some of these feelings that
they perhaps otherwise
wouldn't express in an opera or
in a symphony, or in some
larger scale work.
Shostakovich did that and
in the Soviet Union.
When he had something to say
that he didn't want to be too
scrutinized by the upper echelon
of the government, so
he put it in a string quartet--
sort of worked it
into his music.
And the string quartet
typically has a small
audience, so it didn't get the
kind of feature that his
operas, which often got
him into trouble, did.
But this work by Britten is
just a charming work.
Britten, a lot like Schubert, a
lot like Mozart, was writing
music from a very,
very young age.
Felix Mendelssohn
was another one.
Music just seemed to come
out of their pores.
And his mother, Benjamin
Britten's mother, fully
anticipated that her son would
become the fourth B--
after Bach, Beethoven,
and Brahms.
Brahms lived in great fear that
Bruckner would become the
fourth B. But Britten--
I don't know if he's considered
the fourth B, but
we love his music.
This is three movements.
The first is a march, and the
second movement is a beautiful
waltz, and the third movement is
a very almost rambunctious
country dance.
He wrote this pieces, I believe,
as descriptions of
three of his good friends
from his youth.
And I don't know much more
about them, but you can
extrapolate what you can from
hearing these three vignettes.
The repertoire is so fast that
if we spent, as we have, our
entire adult lives--
supposedly we are adults--
playing this music, we'll never
get through it all.
Not on the level that
we want to play it.
So we're very fortunate
in terms of that.
And the vehicle, the string
quartet as an art form, and as
a vehicle for music, and to go
places as an ensemble is
remarkable.
The four of us, all we really
need are four chairs, although
we could play three
of us standing up.
And Sandy actually doesn't sound
too bad when he stands
up with the cello.
I think he and Yo Yo Ma have
the record on that.
But four chairs.
We bring our own stands with us,
we buy a seat for Sandy's
cello wherever we
go in the world.
It often flies first
or business class.
It doesn't play word
or anything.
SANDY WILSON: [INAUDIBLE].
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: Sometimes he
does, sometimes he doesn't.
But if you see four people with
instruments sitting in
four separate sections
of the plane, it's
probably a string quartet.
And not speaking
to each other.
But we do spend a lot
of time together.
And the four of us can go into
a wonderful setting like this
here at Google.
We can go in, as we do,
through San Francisco
Performances, through
so many other means.
Into classrooms, into inner
city schools to play in an
even closer setting than this--
children, high school
students, who perhaps never had
the opportunity to hear
something like this in their
lives, and they stand or sit
three feet away from Sandy's
cello or something.
They can feel the vibrations in
a way that their electronic
reproductions just don't give
when they listen to music, and
it becomes an extraordinary
visceral experience.
So the quartet as an art form is
a lot easier to get around
than a symphony.
The repertoire is vast.
Not to be mistaken that I
don't value symphonic
repertoire, or other things.
You don't have to tune it like
a piano-- you just tune 16
strings instead of 600.
But now it's your turn.
If you have any questions at
all, anything you've been
dying to know, anything
you'd like to--
please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
Can you tell us a bit more about
the circumstances under
which some of the early quartets
of Mozart, Haydn,
Beethoven, were performed?
Were they done for members of
the public, or for friends?
Did they do an entire couple of
quartets in an evening, or
did they just play in
[INAUDIBLE] movements?
Things like that.
PAUL YARBROUGH: Well,
great question.
Something we have to bear in
mind when we play this music,
that it was almost entirely
inaccessible to the general
public, really.
It was the domain of
the aristocracy.
These were people who lived in
palaces, and had the funds to
have a retinue of musicians,
perhaps in their employ.
Or they were just from finer
families in Vienna who would
have musicales and would
invite the interesting
musicians of the day to come
and perform in their home.
And if you were fortunate enough
to have an invitation,
you could hear the music.
Or if you were among the very
few people, but a growing
class of people, who actually
were beginning to rise up into
a sort of a beginning middle
class, and those people could
actually afford to learn to play
instruments and enjoy the
music in their own--
this music has two purposes.
One is a performance aspect,
and the other is a
participation aspect.
And so during the early years,
it was considered a mark of
very good training and breeding
that you could take a
hand and play a part in the
string quartet with other
people who are like minded, and
that was a sort of, you
might say, kind of an
enlightenment idea, that
everyone could play and
participate in this music,
which is such a rarefied
thing.
And those people, when they came
to hear a concert or a
performance of some kind,
had high expectations.
They knew the music, how it
would be structured, what was
likely to be the formal
structure of each of the
movements in the quartet.
And there wasn't the same
prohibition against clapping
between movements, or even, at
that point, during movements.
If you were turned on by
something that was done in the
moment, just like you would in
a jazz performance, somebody
takes a solo and everybody
claps, and then it moves on.
But that was not so unusual
in those times.
Now it's become very stiff,
which we try, to some extent,
to counteract the stuffiness
or formality of classical
music concerts.
On the other hand, we
appreciate, too, when people
are really attentive and silent,
and not clinking
glasses and talking loudly
and so forth.
So I know some of the jazz
musicians, we say, [INAUDIBLE]
club environment is so cool.
It seems so personal
and so unstuffy.
And they say, yeah, but people
are drinking and talking while
you're playing.
They kind of crave
what we have--
the silent audience
in a concert hall.
I hope I answered your
question adequately.
ZAKARIAS GRAFILO: There's also
some wonderful stories of the
composers themselves
playing together--
Mozart and Haydn getting
together, reading through
their latest string quartets,
and that's kind of how they
communicated.
It was like, I can do that
better than you kind of thing.
But, I mean, for us, musicians,
thinking about
being a fly on the wall,
watching some of these reading
sessions, is just amazing.
I wish I could go back and see
what that must have been like
during first performances
of those works.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious if
you could comment on--
there's a lot of discussion
about the impact of technology
on the music industry lately,
and the transition to digital.
And a lot of that is more about
popular music, and I
know classical is sort of a much
smaller niche in terms of
the recording industry.
But if you could comment on what
impact that's had on your
career, which has obviously
spanned that transition, and
also how you feel like
it's impacted
classical music overall.
SANDY WILSON: I think
very well.
I think we're still here,
we're thriving.
We actually--
over 30 years, we've certainly
seen a lot of changes.
It's a hell of a lot less
expensive to record now, and
the ability to record really
well, and to control the
circumstances under which your
work is encoded for posterity.
We have a lot more influence
over that.
Of course, it's prolific.
And the ability to saturate the
market with substandard
work is unfortunate.
PAUL YARBROUGH: Along those
lines, we actually, after many
unfortunate experiences of
recording and trying to have
our work distributed well, and
nurtured, if you will, after
the fact of our making
recordings, we decided the
only alternative was to
make our own company.
So we started our own record
label about 20 years ago.
We have done work for other
labels, but we pride ourselves
in this set of recordings that
we've made, and the amount of
time and love we lavish
on these projects--
not only the musical side of it,
but also the information
inside the booklets, and the
photography, and the graphic
design, and everything.
We read now that most people
under a certain age have never
even bought a CD.
They get everything
electronically, and probably
without paying for it.
So that's a matter
of some concern.
But I still think there are a
lot of people who like the
physical, the tangible product,
and don't mind buying
it and keeping it.
Maybe then they put it on their
different devices and
use it in different ways, but I,
for one, still like to sit
down and look at liner notes
while I listen to a piece of
music, and enjoy whatever
commentary the artists
themselves might have included
in the booklet.
So hopefully there's still going
to be a market for just
hard products of recordings.
But the other thing is, we do
have to be a little bit
involved in this change, in the
revolution that's involved.
We play 250-year-old
instruments, and 200 and
something year old music a
lot of the time, and all.
But we're still 21st century
artists, and we need to be up
to date, at least somewhat.
Anyway, I don't know
if that's a good--
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: I want to
add that my friends who've
done very well, often in
[INAUDIBLE], have all been
buying vinyl, and paying a lot
of money, in some cases, for
record covers that have smudges
on them and other
things, sometimes with great
history-- which you can't do
with certain other things.
So it's kind of--
I know it's a small niche, but
it's an interesting thing.
And a lot of the great recording
engineers we work
say that the analog still is
their preferred mode of
listening to things.
And so it depends on
who you talk to.
But the control issue that
Sandy [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, we did a Beethoven cycle
for BMG years ago, and I
think at a certain point,
it just got buried.
And they owned it anywhere in
the universe, in any format.
And then when we did our own,
they rereleased our old one to
try to compete with it.
And that's just the way
the world works.
But we had the choice
to do our own.
And as Paul also mentioned,
old music.
But we do a lot of new music,
too, and are able to
commission works through
friends, and
through other means--
foundations.
And that's a very vital thing--
part of what we feel
is that the quartet shouldn't
be a museum piece.
It really should be living
today as well.
ZAKARIAS GRAFILO: I want to say
also, of course, wonderful
technologies that are costly,
and therefore, I think they
still remain in the domain
of the major mega labels.
But we have had a chance to do
some surround sound recordings
recently, 24-bit, the extra
dimensions, and we actually
haven't heard the results
of that yet.
So the vote's still out on
whether it's something we
should aspire to.
But I know that there are
wonderful technologies.
One thing that we would love to
try to figure out how to do
is to manage to record in an
acoustical setting in a way
that we could isolate
our voices.
Sort of in a pie
sort of sense.
So you can do music minus
one, or two, or three.
And I know an awful lot of
very accomplished amateur
musicians would love
to sit in.
So we've yet to figure out
how to manage that.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: Or
if he just got tired
of hearing me play.
SANDY WILSON: Quadrophonic.
Yeah.
But the act of actually doing it
is still a challenge, with
accomplishing that isolation
and still keeping the
sightlines and--
anyway, that's just things
to play around with.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
One is that I'm very curious
about your individual
instruments.
If you can show us, and then
maybe tell me about those
things-- like, how many years
old, and how you like it, and
kind of stuff.
And the other thing is that I
was sitting over there, and
there was a speaker there.
It really magnifies the music in
one way or another, and I'm
really, really curious to see
without anything at all.
And then what it used to be,
when they had in a castle, in
a [? new ?] room, and
listening to.
So I was wondering if we can get
the opportunity to have to
have that experience.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: I'll give it
a shot, like the emperor's
new clothes.
First, about the instruments.
You want to start?
Start with the first violin.
ZAKARIAS GRAFILO: This is a
modern fiddle made in 1992, by
a German maker named
Michael Fisher.
It's a copy of a [INAUDIBLE].
SANDY WILSON: You
played that--
we actually played
at the Library of
Congress quite recently.
ZAKARIAS GRAFILO: There's a real
model at the Library of
Congress that was owned by Fritz
Kreisler that I played
on a couple years ago, which
is-- when I played on it, I
was like, wow.
It's like my old violin.
So I was quite pleased to
play on that violin.
SANDY WILSON: The security
folks were kind of--
ZAKARIAS GRAFILO: They were
watching me pretty closely.
SANDY WILSON: Very careful.
Try to get out of the Library
of Congress with a fiddle.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: That'd
be a great movie.
Strip search on aisle three.
But this violin was made by a
maker named Francis Kuttner.
He lives in San Francisco,
and in Cremona, Italy.
Most of the time in Cremona.
And he made this violin
in 2006 for me.
He made a set of instruments for
a good friend of ours that
we've actually recorded a number
of CDs on that were
modeled on the Stradivari
instruments.
This one is more
his own design.
And Sandy plays, also, I'll just
tie that in, on a cello
by Francis Kuttner
but much older.
SANDY WILSON: Well,
this one is 1980.
I didn't buy it in 1980.
I acquired this just about five
years ago, and I still
have a lovely 1702
cello at home.
And if ever you want to buy
a nice 19th century French
cello, see me afterwards.
But this was the gold medal
winner in the [INAUDIBLE]
violin building competition in
that year, and I love it.
We can tell you a little bit
about why we play modern
instruments--
some of us.
PAUL YARBROUGH: Or
why I don't.
SANDY WILSON: He can't
afford it.
He wouldn't have paid them
enough, actually.
PAUL YARBROUGH: This is the only
instrument in the quartet
that actually could have
participated in the premier
performance of any of these
works that we play today,
because it was made in
1750 in Genoa, Italy.
The maker's name is Costello.
I play modern instruments, too,
from time to time, and I
often love them very much.
It's sort of a myth
that the only good
instruments are old ones.
Instruments do tend to improve
with age, but if they weren't
really great to start with,
they're not going to become
great with time.
So finding an instrument that's
really right for you as
an individual that you're
able to express
yourself on is the trick.
And if you're lucky enough to
be able to find a new one,
that's nice, because it's
a lot less expensive.
The old ones are very valuable
for antique and collectible
reasons, but not necessarily for
the quality of the sound
that they make.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: With the
exception of the really great
ones, and we're talking about
instruments, in many cases,
that are Stradivari and
[INAUDIBLE] instruments that
are valued at about $5
millsion, $6 million.
And none of us want to sell
our children or pets or
anything to buy them.
PAUL YARBROUGH: I don't
think my kids would
bring that much, actually.
But I'd think about it.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: But
they are magnificent.
I have to say that when we get
together and play with friends
who do play on these
instruments, and hear them
side by side, these
do very well.
You asked an important
question.
Do we love them, or how
do we like them?
And the answer is I really
do love the instrument.
And all of us have played on
some older instruments-- and
I'm also selling an instrument,
not here, today.
But it's because I think it
should be played by a young
player that really loves it.
And I don't need to have more
than one instrument.
I also have another instrument
that's in that set that we use
quite often, and its model, as
I said, is on the Stradivari,
and it's a little brighter.
And as a second violinist, I
tend more to use it in the
quartet, and right now, it's
getting a new bridge on it.
Francis has flown in from
Cremona for a few weeks.
So I play on this,
which is my own.
But I love them both.
And we have to make sure that
our colleagues are happy with
our instruments, whether
we like it or not.
The four of us are practically
married in that regard.
And if things aren't happy at
home, it's just not happy.
So when I was buying this
violin, Sandy said--
I wasn't quite sure if I was
going to buy an instrument,
and Sandy said, it'll make
your life a lot easier.
And sometimes it does.
But you wanted to hear them
without any amplification.
I think we can do that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: This won't
be a listening quiz.
This will be first part
of the second movement
of the Mozart quartet.
[INAUDIBLE] allegretto.
And this is a lovely space,
and we do appreciate our
fantastic engineer.
[INAUDIBLE].
SANDY WILSON: Just want
to do [INAUDIBLE]?
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: Yeah.
[MUSIC - MOZART]
PAUL YARBROUGH: Better
with, or without?
AUDIENCE: Without.
PAUL YARBROUGH: Number
two, OK.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: You
have a question.
AUDIENCE: So I remember when I
was studying chamber music, my
group would listen to tons of
recordings of other groups
playing the same pieces, and
evaluate them, and decide
which one we liked best, and
watch tons of YouTube videos
of different performances.
But I was wondering,
what's your, like--
an established quartet?
Do you ever go check out the
Saint Lawrence Quartet in
residency at Stanford to hear
some of their performances?
Or I know members of the San
Francisco Company sometimes do
Sunday chamber music
performances for fun.
Do you ever listen to
any of those, or--
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: That's
a great question.
I don't know the Saint
Lawrence--
I'm just kidding.
It's funny.
Yes and no.
Part of it's-- some of us
do, more than others.
Some of us--
sometimes Zak, who knows how
to use YouTube and other
things will send us things
to listen to.
I used to listen quite a bit.
When we first started, and the
quartet lived in New York, I
would go here a number of
quartets, because you'd just
walk out your door in Lincoln
Center, and hear all your
colleagues, and see them.
Now I tend to just bump into
people in airports and chat
about families and kids
and old teachers.
But it is important, I
think, to listen to
other artists play.
In my particular situation, my
feeling is, I listen to other
works in other genres outside
of the string quartet.
I'll do a lot more listening
to songs, opera, by these
various composers, and we
all like a lot of music.
And there's only so much
time in the day.
And also, if I want to listen
to something in my car, it's
usually going to be what my
kids want to listen to.
I have a 7-year-old and a
14-year-old, so you can use
your imagination.
It's not Mozart's
string quartets.
Even though they like
to come once in a
while to the concert.
But I do occasionally hear
things, and the answer is, I
do learn from my colleagues,
and from young groups that
come and play for us.
We've had a couple of groups
like the [INAUDIBLE] and
others that have
worked with us.
They've become world
class ensembles.
And they will send us things.
Zak is working on producing
their first recording.
And I learn a lot from
hearing other people.
But I don't particularly
spend a lot of time.
I think you listen more.
ZAKARIAS GRAFILO: I listen
a fair amount still.
When I was a student, I used to
listen to recordings quite
a bit, and I still have
a lot of recordings
that I go back to.
I don't listen as much
as I did in the past.
I probably would like
to listen to more.
Going to live concerts, probably
hardly ever nowadays,
mostly because we're so busy.
We're so busy teaching, we're
so busy rehearsing, playing
our own concerts.
And I don't know if I had the
free time, if I would
necessarily want to go to
see string quartets.
I think since we spend so much
time doing it ourselves, like
what Fred said, kind of getting
away from what we do
every day is kind of nice.
But I spend a fair amount of
time on YouTube, and watch
videos, and listen
to recordings.
It's fun, when I do have
the time late at night.
SANDY WILSON: I have
to chime in.
Recently, there was a movie,
some of you may have seen it,
called A Late Quartet.
It was mostly in art cinema
houses and such, but Philip
Seymour Hoffman and Christopher
Walken were in
this movie.
They were both in the
string quartet.
And I went, at the sort of
urging of a friend of mine,
who really wanted to see it and
really wanted me to come
and see it, too, with her.
And so I went.
And I thought I was going to
hate it, because I thought it
was just going to be baloney.
It's not really like
this, you know?
And of course, then you have
to watch these people who
don't really play instruments
pretend to be playing
instruments, which is kind
of painful for us.
But in the end, I really thought
it was terrific.
I haven't been able
to persuade anyone
else to go see it.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: I went
to see it, and it
wasn't showing anymore.
SANDY WILSON: Yeah.
But it really was quite
well done, I thought.
And they did a lot of fact
checking, and they must have
had some great consultation to
get the internal things in
quartets kind of right.
It was funny--
one of the first scenes, there's
some problem after
which we discover that the
cellist has incipient
Parkinson's disease.
But the first violinist stops,
and he says, our vibratos
aren't matching.
And I went, like, did
I hear him say that?
Because it's exactly
the thing that we
would say to one another.
So they really did do
a good job in that.
I had to tell you about that,
because I thought that movie
was very insightful for
what you asked.
Do we still immerse ourselves
in all this stuff?
And to some extent, we do.
But also, we need a break.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much.
How have your careers evolved
differently than, perhaps, the
vision that you set yourselves
when you first started?
And as you're trying to
establish yourselves as young
artists, what hurdles did you
face that perhaps surprised
you, and you had to find
creative solutions for?
SANDY WILSON: Well, if you had
told me when I was 19 years
old that at the age I am now,
which I won't say, that I
would be playing in a string
quartet, performing widely,
teaching at a university,
teaching music, and making a
living, I would've said
where do I sign?
I mean, this life that I live
is almost exactly what I
dreamt of as a young musician
starting out.
So I'm really very,
very fortunate.
As far as the challenges that
we face, I think the hardest
part has always been that
as a quartet you're
like a small startup--
a business where you can't
afford to just do your own
narrow area of expertise.
You have to wear
a lot of hats.
And everybody has to be willing
to do things that
weren't necessarily part
of their curriculum and
conservatory.
Like, think about finances and
grant applications, and how to
organize students into chamber
music ensembles, and keep the
ruffled feathers from
flaring up.
And I mean, we do a lot of
things for ourselves.
We book our own travel, we drive
our own rental cars.
And everything is kind
of small scale.
And if you like that, if that
kind of endeavor is
fulfilling, then
this is great.
If you really hate doing
anything for yourself--
I mean, the symphony musicians,
they sit their
suitcases outside their hotel
room, and someone picks it up
and puts it in the truck, and
they show up when they're
supposed to be there and play
their instruments, and that's
pretty much it.
They don't really need to do
all these other things.
For us, it's impossible for
us to hire people to do
everything that we need to do.
So as a small business, we're
kind of on our own.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: I never
thought I would agree 100%
with Paul, because in a string
quartet, you hardly do.
But actually, I think he said
it quite beautifully.
I grew up watching two things
growing up in Boston-- the
Boston Celtics, and the great
string quartets that came
through to Harvard University
and to Jordan
Hall, and other things.
And it was my dream to play
second violin in one of the
great quartets, because I was
enamored with some of the
second violinists.
So my other side of that was the
Boston Celtics, but I was
a little challenged in
some areas there.
So I play in other
types of parquet
floors, but with a violin.
So actually, I think when I
joined the quartet-- that's
another thing about--
I talked to my brothers, who
are in business and in
software and in other things.
And another thing about
the quartet--
when I joined this quartet, I
fully anticipated that I would
lose a little hair, become
gray, and see myself--
I saw myself as a lifetime
commitment.
It was 26 years ago when
I joined these guys.
And I haven't changed that sense
of commitment to it.
We do from time to time get
upset with each other.
We function as a group,
like a democracy.
But we don't have
majority rule.
All four of us have to agree
100% on every decision we
make, whether it's where we
play, what fee we accept, what
airline we fly, or we fly
separate flights.
All this stuff, we have to agree
100%, or we don't do it.
So three to one doesn't win.
So that also has kept us very
vested in what we do.
But as far as a career, as far
as the dreams of a young kid--
I mean, until I look in the
mirror, I still think I'm like
16 or 17 years old.
And according to my wife,
I act a little younger.
So I fully anticipate, as Paul
said, I would be doing this.
I would be here with you all
today, playing Schubert and
Mozart, and loving it.
So I'm pretty lucky.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming today.
I was wondering if you could
comment on the sort of
interplay between technique and
musicality, and whether
you're making decisions based on
expediency, or based on the
quality of the music.
ZAKARIAS GRAFILO: That's a
really great question, and I
think that's something that we,
as professional musicians,
struggle with throughout
our careers--
trying to find ways to be
efficient, but still
speak to the music.
I don't know if I have a
real answer for you.
I think it's something
that, like I said, we
struggle with every day.
We rehearse every day for four
or five hours in the morning,
and these are the kinds of
things that we talk about.
We're constantly checking
each other.
Is this a good musical idea?
Does this make sense
interpretively?
But we are also talking about
mechanics, too-- the mechanics
of playing together, the
mechanics of playing in tune,
the mechanics of matching
our vibratos,
matching the bow speeds.
So there's always
a balance there
between those two things.
The mechanics of playing and
playing together, and being
musical, and interpreting the
music the best possible way.
SANDY WILSON: It's something
that's particularly rewarding,
when you do it in an intimate
team like this with three
other people.
Because you draw on the
amplitudes and the strengths
of one another.
There are some things that
somebody's going to hate to
do, but that somebody else just
loves to roll up their
sleeves and get in with that.
So we might have the intonation
Nazi, or the
vibrato Nazi, or the guy who's
going to say, no, we just have
to routine this.
We're going to slow this down.
We're doing this spot, we're
doing that spot.
But the process, we've
refined it.
There are certainly some times
when we're really under the
gun, and we go into the practice
room and say, we
really have to microwave this.
We're not going to
make it on time.
We pull extra rehearsals.
We do what we have to do,
and our families pay.
I mean, they really--
it's a family business.
We all have spouses and
kids, and it's tough.
I don't think that many
orchestral musicians--
professionals--
really understand what the life
of the string quartet is.
They will tell us, and we'll nod
in appreciation when they
tell us, oh, you guys
are so lucky.
It's just fantastic--
you're doing everything
we wanted to do.
But it's like, as Paul says, I
mean, these guys just show up
at the concert.
The bus takes them there, and
their tailcoats are already
pressed, their shoes
are polished.
They just have to go out,
play the concert,
and then that's it.
It's not like that.
This is really--
it's a grind.
But the reward is that we are
all doing exactly what I think
we aspired to do, even if
we didn't know we did.
It's so satisfying,
to go to work and
to have people applaud.
It's a wonderful privilege.
And I think we recognize
it as a privilege.
We really do recognize
we're also--
we've been very lucky to be
still doing this into our
fourth decade now.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: I think the
great thing about the quartet,
and I think why a lot of young
people get excited about it,
is that you are a member
of a team.
You're part of an ensemble.
But you're also a soloist,
because of the transparency.
You're the only one
who's playing
that part in the group.
And so you have really the
best of both worlds.
And it's a fine balancing act.
I also have to say, much
like Sandy just said--
I used to play for [INAUDIBLE]
in the Boston Symphony.
When my colleagues come and hear
us play, or hear us on
the radio, or hear one of our
recordings, and they say,
you've gotten so much better.
I can't imagine how bad
I was at the time.
But it it's really a testament
to the kind of criticism--
daily criticism, and support
that we get from one another.
Because we know that you
have to balance--
and I think it's true in any
business-- you have to balance
how hard you push each other and
the effectiveness with the
overall health of the
organization.
And we're not an organization
where people quit very often,
or resign, or leave.
There've been very few changes
in the quartet.
I'm the second second violinist
in 31 years, and Zak
is maybe the fourth
first violinist.
The first one didn't stay very
long, the second one did for a
few years, and the third
one 10 years out.
But we go through first
violinists.
But we've also known
Zak a long time.
We've known him since he was
a kid in San Francisco.
So it's a real balancing
act in the work
that we have to do.
Thank you for having us today.
The San Francisco
Performance--
Virginia-- for bringing
us down here.
We don't live that far away, so
if you ever want to have us
back, I think you know
how to find us.
And you can Google us
and find out more.
I always wanted to
say that there.
Because it's just part
of our life.
And, I mean, my kids think
they're so smart, because they
can Google everything.
And that's not a substitute
for intelligence, but it's
very useful.
But it's really been
a pleasure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't know what he's
talking about.
FREDERICK LIFSITZ: Yeah.
And thank you, Cliff, so
much for all this.
So we'll be packing
our things up.
If you want to take a look at
the instruments, or chat a
little bit, some of us won't be
running right out the door.
So thank you.